Oh what day is it oh [ __ ] I have a  conference call in 60 seconds  should I go for a smokey eye or a dewy  look today Yeah right I'm being so  productive this morning look at that  already answered an email killing it you  know what I think I deserve some  pandemic pancakes for breakfast  oh man mates to mess well better clean  this up  might as well clean the whole kitchen  while I'm at it and vacuum the living  room and the bathroom well after all  that I deserve a break  hi mom just making sure you and dad  aren't leaving the house oh sorry about  that guy spending back-to-back meetings  all morning  well now I'm starving should I get a  tick-tock nah  [Applause]  [Music]  yeah yes I know it's funny our roles are  reversed but you still can't leave  [Music]  no I haven't checked the news in a while  [Music]  should I get Animal Crossing now I'll be  more productive tomorrow  [Music]